this
[Music]
is one of the most dramatic skulls from
our prehistoric planet
it belonged to a plant-eating dinosaur
called Triceratops
this dinosaur is instantly recognizable
from the massive fill at the back of its
head
but 140 years after the first fossil was
found scientists are still asking
what was the film for
these are enormous structures so it's an
enormous investment in bone and in
tissue and also in the muscular effort
to hold these structures up
all of this investment must mean that
these features are very important to the
animal's way of life
but how
evidence of injury on Triceratops
fossils suggests that the fills were
important in defense and combat
we can see lesions on the skull which
are areas where the skull has been
damaged and healed
we can also see where a predator has
taken a chunk out of a frill that might
indicate that we're looking at some sort
of defensive structure
another possibility is that the flu was
used to attract prospective mates
we see this in living animals where
structures like horns show off how
healthy they are and who's a good
Prospect for producing lots of young
[Music]
chancellors makes the male more
attractive
vital when it reaches sexual maturity
could the same apply to their
triceratopsis film
if it was only for defense then we would
expect to see them develop to the same
degree in juveniles as in adults but we
don't
we see them being much smaller in the
juveniles and not really developing into
the very very large structures of the
adults until much later
[Music]
this isn't the only evidence that they
were used in sexual display
the surfaces of the Frills are very
heavily grooved
these grooves probably carried nerves
and blood vessels that would have
supplied the skin growing over those
frills
this may have been very brightly colored
a big surface area for the animal to
show off to potential mates
scientists now believe that the Christ
terrorist Ops is best known feature was
truly multi-purpose
very useful for attack and defense
but also ideal for attracting a mate
[Music]
it would have been an awe-inspiring
sight to Friend or Foe
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
foreign